then read yourself just looking at these
eobeochigi lose this stuff it's not good
for your knee it's not consistent with
other arts or other sports right so I
get everything I humming in the knee
comes to the toes that's as far as I go
if I needed more penetration which
should I've done take a bigger step
moving right so don't overturn the knees
now out of alignment don't cave in he's
not alignment with the foot okay now
once I get that arm the rear cross
barrier chain so the weight line of his
body is what is mid-foot mid foot so
just like if I squirm here step staff as
the force line dole over lead and get on
your toes whoa activate your the rear
posterior chain do exam now throw on the
mid foot should feel the squat